dans Captain America, le soldat de l'hiver,
nous introduisons un nouveau personnage appelé
Sam Wilson
le faucon Sam Wilson Steve Rogers J'ai en
quelque sorte rassemblé cela jusqu'à un
certain point dans le film où il ne sait pas à
qui il peut faire confiance parfois la
personne dont vous avez besoin  faire confiance est un étranger
et c'est là que Sam intervient en pensant que
vous avez dit que vous étiez pilote
Je n'ai jamais dit pilote Sam Wilson c'est un
gars debout et il travaille avec Captain
America et le suit à travers cette
épreuve parce qu'il croit en
qui a fait de lui un  fait partie d'une
équipe de parachutistes de l'armée et c'est une
combinaison de vol très avancée qui lui permet de
voler en engageant le Falcon
sera un ajout amusant et intéressant à l'univers de la casquette
et sera un héros à sa
manière comment connaissons-nous les bons gars  des
méchants s'ils vous tirent
dessus, ils sont mauvais ce n'est pas tant un film de super-héros qu'un film d'
action axé sur les personnages c'est
vraiment amusant pura il est temps que
vous